the two richest men in the world have a
long history of squabbling over their
ambitions in space to understand the
rivalry we have to go back to 2004. when
musk and bezos met for a dinner
according to christian davenport's book
the space barons musk tried to give some
tips to the amazon ceo about building
rockets saying i actually did my best to
give good advice which he largely
ignored their space companies were just
startups at the time bezos who has
always been infatuated with space had
the means to start blue origin in 2000
as he was flush with cash from amazon
bezos is so keen he recently stepped
down as ceo of amazon to focus more
attention on a space company musk
started spacex two years later with the
money he made when his company was sold
to paypal which was then bought by ebay
they spent the first decade building up
their respective ventures without a lot
of bickering but that all changed in
2013. when spacex secured a long-term
lease of launch pad 39a at nasa's
kennedy space center in florida where
the apollo moon missions took off from
bezos wasn't very happy about the deal
blue origin filed a formal protest with
nasa to prevent spacex from using it
exclusively arguing it should be turned
into a commercial spaceport available to
all launch companies in reaction must
call the protest a phony blocking tactic
in an email to space news and said
spacex would accommodate blue origin
should their vehicle be launch ready but
he couldn't resist taking a swipe at
blue origin slow progress writing
frankly i think we are more likely to
discover unicorns dancing in the flame
duct spacex secured a 20-year lease of
the historic launch pad the next year it
was spacex that had beef with blue
origin in 2014 the u.s patent and
trademark office granted blue origin a
patent for landing rocket boosters on
drone ships this would have meant that
spacex would have to pay to use the
technology spacex argued that the
concept of drone ships had been around
for decades a judge sided with musk's
firm forcing blue origin to withdraw
most of its patent claims since then
spacex has successfully landed its
falcon 9 boosters on drone ships 66
times to date the first time was in
april 2016 on the ship of course i still
love you spacex achieved successful
launch after a successful launch that
year bezos tried to poach spacex's
president and ceo gwynne shotwell
according to the book amazon unbound by
bradstone but shotwell declined the job
of blue origin's ceo it would go to bob
smith musk has had an issue with blue
origin's hiring practices he told ashley
vance who wrote a biography about him
that blue origin's tactic has been to
snag away talent from spacex by offering
double their salaries adding i think
it's unnecessary and a bit rude while
spacex has sprinted ahead blue origin
has progressed at a far slower pace it
successfully landed new shepard for the
first time in 2015 after which bezos
tweeted it was the rarest of beasts a
used rocket to which musk pointed out it
wasn't exactly rare spacex did the same
with its prototype grasshopper three
years before in 2012 and blue origin
still has not gone into orbit it carried
passengers for the first time on a
suborbital flight in july bezos and
three crewmates flew past the carmen
line the internationally recognized
boundary of space before returning to
earth on the other hand spacex has gone
into orbit with a falcon 9 over a
hundred times including taking
astronauts to the international space
station both billionaires have their
sights set on sending people much
farther when spacex beat out blue origin
to win a coveted contract with nasa to
land the next humans on the moon using
this modified starship must stroke bezos
in blue origin can't get it up to orbit
and speaking of sexual innuendos musk
also poked fun at the name of blue
origin's lunar lander blue moon tweeting
putting the word blue on a ball is
questionable branding blue origin is
suing nasa for awarding spacex that
contract worth 2.9 billion the
government agency originally planned on
investing in two lunar landers going
forward the choices were spacex blue
origin and dynetics however budget
concerns and a lack of funding from
congress scuttled those plans forcing
nasa to choose just one blue origin
feels it's dangerous choosing only one
company writing in an open letter on its
website competition will prevent any
single source from having insurmountable
leverage over nasa and even created this
infographic blasting spacex's starship
the contract is only for an uncrewed
test flight and the first crude landing
on the moon blue origin and other
companies can still bid on further
contracts however blue origin argues
that spacex now has a huge head start
and after this loss blue origin lost a
lead engineer who had been working on
the lunar lander nitin aurora announced
in a linkedin post he was moving over to
spacex bezos other company amazon also
has a problem with spacex's satellite
internet service starlink over a
thousand starling satellites have
already been launched serving 90 000
customers worldwide according to spacex
the company aims to launch many
thousands more however amazon has urged
the federal communications commission
the fcc to reject spacex's updated plans
that call for two different satellite
configurations arguing spacex should
have made these changes before filing
its application not after why does
amazon care because it plans to launch
its own satellite internet service
project kuiper which led musk to call
bezos a copycat there's no word on when
amazon service will start operating
spacex responded to amazon's protest by
calling it a continuation of efforts by
the amazon family of companies to hinder
competitors to compensate for amazon's
failure to make progress of its own it
also noted that amazon has lodged
objections to spacex on average about
every 16 days this year musk then
followed that up by tweeting filing
legal actions against spacex is actually
bezos's full-time job spacex is banking
that its high-speed internet service
will bring in billions of much-needed
dollars to fund the colonization of mars
settling on mars is not an idea bezos
likes at all he's made veiled comments
about musk's plans once saying mount
everest would be a garden paradise
compared to living on the freezing red
planet he also took a shot at one of the
reasons musk wants to reside on mars in
case earth were to get destroyed bezos
called this kind of backup plan very
unmotivating without naming the spacex
ceo on the other hand bezos envisions a
universe populated by floating space
colonies that hold a million people some
of which can resemble our own cities in
order to take the pressure off of
earth's resources but blue origin
doesn't have a timeline to turn his
vision into reality nor has it discussed
how big of a role it would play in
trying to make this happen whereas
spacex is operating with concrete goals
in mind musk has said he's aiming to
send people to the red planet for the
first time by 2026 on starship it all
depends on the rate of progress of the
gigantic launch vehicle which is under
development in south texas spacex
conducted its first test flight of
starship in december 2020 a huge
achievement that even bezos acknowledged
posting on instagram anybody who knows
how hard this stuff is is impressed by
today's starship test big congrats to
the whole spacex team blue origin is now
working on its own answer to starship
new glenn was originally designed to
have a reusable first stage but not a
reusable upper stage however the company
is reportedly working on making the
second stage reusable as well to compete
with starship which is a fully reusable
rocket the secretive blue origin project
has been codenamed jarvis when someone
on twitter suggested that blue origin is
acting like a kid copying someone's
homework musk replied with laughing
emojis new glenn was supposed to go in
its maiden voyage in late 2021 that has
now been pushed to late 2022 blue
origin's motto is gradim ferocitare
which in latin means step by step
ferociously but at its pace so far musk
jokingly dismissed the idea that blue
origin was a true competitor in an
interview with the bbc a few years ago
you're obviously a very competitive
person you're competing with the likes
of jeff bezos
uh in jeffree
and it's likely that this kind of banter
will continue if you'd like to learn
more about how humans will survive on
mars and how our bodies will physically
adapt to the change there's a great
series on curiosity stream called
becoming martian my sponsor curiosity
stream has documentaries on everything
you're curious about one of my favorite
shows of all time is redesign my brain
where host todd sampson goes through
specific exercises to become smarter and
more creative so you're going to see a
series of of letters flash by and in the
middle of those letters are going to be
numbers the task is to remember those
numbers you saw one what was the other
didn't see it didn't say it okay your
turn there are documentaries on tech
science space and history if you head to
curiositystream.com
newsthink and use my discount code
newsthink you'll save 25 off your
membership so that curiosity stream is
only 15 for the entire year my custom
link is in the description thanks so
much for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm